beloved youth ministers welcome we're so
grateful you're here the flurries did
not discourage you and once again we are
proving there is such a thing as a free
lunch and a bonus lecture so thank you
for coming thank you for what you do in
youth ministry I'd like to introduce
introduce just a couple of people who
are important and our lies and therefore
I hope in your life Carolyn engelhart is
here Carolyn over here Thank You Carolyn
Carolyn runs the ministry resource
center on the Yale Divinity School
campus and she has populated our room
with books and materials on youth
ministry where we are trying to move
this to one stop shopping you make two
hours available you get the book you
need the resources you need the lecture
you need the relationships you need so
thank you carolyn i'd also like to
introduce Lucinda huffaker listen would
you just at least put your hand up while
you finish your sandwich I'm sure
Lucinda has a more exalted title but I
know that she is the director of
supervised ministries here on campus
which means if you are a practitioner or
a youth minister and you're hoping to
attract a student to come as a
supervised ministry in turn you want to
get next to her sometime during the day
and you know make your like you and if
you are a student looking for a
placement you already know that you want
to talk to Lucinda who's our
co-conspirator in religious education
and youth ministry on campus amen and
that leads me to one little additional
thing I hope you saw these papers on
youth ministry fellows so if you are at
a church and you would like to have a
youth ministry initiative fellow at your
church that creates the possibility of
creating more opportunities for Yale
Divinity School students to get
experience in youth ministry if they
happen to be on track for a supervised
ministry internship it can qualify see
Lucinda as a supervised ministry
requirement for ordination but if their
first year students third year students
alumni never went to Divinity School
they can still qualify if they
articulate
interest in a call to youth ministry and
what it gets them is not only an
opportunity to have the experience at
your church and whatever your
compensation structure is but the youth
ministry initiative will supplement that
compensation structure with a four
thousand dollar too we should stipend
that goes right against their tuition
and then we're developing practicums on
campus if they are in the supervised
ministry program they're correcting
while practicum on campus as youth
ministers will count right Lucinda we're
still hopeful for that and even if they
don't they can be part of that body of
reflection that will gather here on the
campus for the fellows so if you are at
a church and you'd like to participate
in this or learn more about it please
contact us and if you are a student or
NOAA student same deal contact us so
that you depart our program which we
hope will continue to encourage folks to
explore vocations to youth ministry
second quick announcement your presence
here is noticed just walking through the
hallways the exalted leaders OVL
university figure out there are actually
people who are interested in youth
ministry I don't know how that escaped
attention everywhere before but it is
not escaping their attention now so
we've been invited say we're on a
conference on youth ministry this summer
as part of the Yale Divinity School
summer term will be running that monday
through friday jun 17 to 21 the courses
at Yale Divinity School summer term were
385 dollars not for you there'll be ten
dollars a day registration fee which
will refund you if you actually pick
your lunch up so you can't you're still
getting your free lunch we already have
chap Clark Miroslav Volf androgynous
yoga have accepted invitations to speak
at that conference please mark your
calendars and we'll see you in June
we're already planning for our programs
next year Roger nishioka has agreed to
come back to this lunch next year ken de
Cressi Dean has agreed to come to the
program
next year so we're off and running now
today I don't want to oversell but I
actually wanted to be on tippy-toes to
get over the bar I'm claiming that we
have today as our speaker the person who
knows the most about youth ministry in
America and I'm going to get there by
claiming as he has shared with me that
Raleigh Martin has been studying
teaching and practicing youth ministry
for 51 years started when he was five
and at his work his work has not only
been as a minister as a youth minister
it has not only been as a theologian and
as a professor you know he has driven
and developed a youth ministry program
at luther seminary that has a hundred
and twenty three students every year
studying to be youth ministers what an
accomplishment over time he's also a
social scientist an academic who has
been running groundbreaking studies and
what are the correlates of successful
youth ministry so the longitudinal Lily
study on what kind of congregations
associate with and are correlated with
successful youth ministries he ran the
program on exemplary youth ministries he
is the Carrie Olson bahlsen professor of
children youth family at luther seminary
and the academic dean is here to talk to
us today about something we all know we
should do we all think we should do
sometimes we even succeed at it in not
only nurturing youth ministries but
integrating them with all the other
generations of the church so we are
delighted to welcome back professor dr.
Rowley Martinson
thank you
it is 51 years but I'm 70 she walked
past me i gingerly passed across from
her hand to mine the sermon notes that
she was to take as a member of the
confirmation class she looked at me and
said warily on Sunday morning you get up
and hand out all these empty pop cans on
Wednesday I hand a few back to you and
nothing much of significance ever passes
between us so what does one say I said
help me unpack that what do you mean
empty pop cans she said since when is
God a three-syllable word
and then she said you talked about that
which doesn't matter and a language that
no one can understand from a point of
view that doesn't make a difference whoa
so I'm scrambling and and I say to her
cell let's talk I mean let's talk get
three to five of your good friends and
sit in the third pew in front of the
pulpit and I will take you up for
breakfast on monday after Sunday and
we'll talk so there they were she and
five of her friends with their pads so I
preached and for the next six weeks we
went out for Monday morning breakfast at
seven o'clock I and the fearsome six and
after about two months of it one day an
elderly woman was walking past me out of
the service and she said what's going on
with your preaching thought oh now the
elders are taking after me and I said
well I don't know why do you ask and she
said you talk about that which matters
in a language that we can understand
from a point of view that makes a
difference I learned that these two
women were grand daughter and
grandmother they ganged up on the
preacher changed my preaching forever
one things I learned is that in bringing
the gospel into the lives of six
generations it's not just kerygma
even galiyon proclamation it is also
marteria witness been there done that
the transformational power of God at
work in the world has in fact swept me
up in the baptismal call of vocation and
I now live a life for the sake of the
neighbor which is interesting and deeply
framed by what God is doing in the
universe so what I want to do with you
today is to wonder about a tripartite
process of the transformative presence
active presence of a god who's real and
at work in the world what that might
look like in the life of a congregation
six generations as the body of Christ
living their identity and mission as a
part of God's life and work age level
ministries that speak to and arise out
of the language of the existential
experience of those whose frontal lobes
are developing and who live in a in a
particular unique world that's matched
by domestic churches that are in fact
living day-to-day the stuff of life
itself congregation age level ministries
and domestic churches at work in each
other's lives and to get us started I
want to put you to work in a particular
way so if someone would get the light
let me just sit in front of you a
parable and then have you go to work
some of you may recognize this it's made
its way around youth ministry and
children ministry circles Peter and
Penny go swimming soon after Peter and
Penny were born their parents began
taking them to the local swimming pool
every weekend the parents were
enthusiastic swimmers and they hope
their children would be keen swimmers
too of course Peter and Penny were not
allowed to go into the swimming pool
itself
they were looked after in a little room
right beside the pool sometimes they
cried because they wanted to stay with
their parents but that wasn't allowed
because they might disturb the adult
swimmers besides they were too young to
understand swimming and they didn't
appreciate it fully when Peter and Penny
were three years old they were allowed
to go to another room just down the hall
from the swimming pool there they heard
stories from the swimmers manual and
they colored pictures of people swimming
and there were six years old Peter and
Penny went to another big room a big
room with lots of children there they
began to get really serious about
swimming for the first 10 or 15 minutes
they were allowed to take off their
shoes and socks and splash around in the
wading pool it then went to classes with
other children their own age to learn
more about swimming they were taught by
some very dedicated people who love
swimming but who hardly who hardly ever
swam themselves anymore because they
were busy with the children by the time
Kenny and Peter were 13 they had studied
the swimmers manual in even more detail
and have learned the rules of the
swimming pool off by heart she'll not
run on the deck you should not bring
flotation devices into the pool area it
also learned about the properties of
water the muscles used in swimming and
the various swimming strokes it studied
great swimmers of the past including
Olympic medal winners they heard about
Canadian swimmers who went to other
countries such as Africa or India to
teach swimming and they had seen slides
of groups of African or Indian swimmers
standing beside their swimming pools on
special occasions Peter and Penny had
been allowed to go with their parents
into the pool as long as they didn't
splash around too much and disturbed the
other swimmers or bother the lifeguard
at last penny and Peter finished
swimming school and were allowed to
accompany their parents into the
swimming pool every week they tried it a
few times must the disappointment of
their parents Peter and Penny had lost
interest and preferred to text instead
so I wonder what such a parable would
look like in the reverse in the negative
that is not what you experience here but
an experience where from the time they
were born Peter and Penny were engaged
in the fullness of the life of the
people of God particularly in this case
and its worship being experienced in
such a way by the time they were 13 14
and older they were so swept up in the
practices of the faith that this was the
place where their tap roots sank deep
into the life-giving streams of God's
presence and the ways in which they
participated in the life of the six
generations were such as Jesus said let
the little children come to me for
rhythum not for them belongs the kingdom
of heaven such that their presence was
in fact the kind of gift that Karen was
to me when she said Raleigh pastor
Raleigh Buster Martinson Reverend
Martinson on Sunday morning you hand out
a few empty pop cans and on Wednesday I
hand if you back to you and nothing
months of significance ever passes
between us a gift she and her
grandmother were incredible gifts around
the table for about three minutes what
would be one thing that one might do
with worship that would in fact have
changed this parable please don't be
bashful if you talk with only three do
that split up but get after it get after
it imagine reimagine what worship might
look like hang on to your life of the
mind your inquiry and imagine what you
were just talking about
to be carried into the conversations of
those who in your congregation have
access to the forming and shaping of its
worship life that the conversation you
have just started would continue and and
unfold and in the process of unfolding
there would be children there would be
teenagers those who are in middle school
and 13 to 18 engaged in the process
imagine such imagine in such a world
that the minister of music is as
interested in the gifts of the Spirit
that are in the congregation to make
music as they are in the performance of
the person playing the organ imagine if
this person went casting about praying
and searching and wondering and picking
up on who has the gift of making music
in Everett Washington I was in such a
congregation there were 39 music groups
in the congregation one of them was that
morning a string quartet made up of
three generations that in fact played
the prelude the youngest the youngest
was seven I nanos uzuki I don't know
what they call the methodology by which
one is somewhat of a prodigy and learns
to play earlier whatever huh I couldn't
imagine a congregation that had person's
doing opera at the same time they had a
person doing lament Psalms Allah
country-western
but this person could and the power the
Holy Spirit did 39 music groups
unleashed in this congregation because
their notion was in the body of Christ
there are persons whom the spirit leads
to make music what I discovered is that
a huge number of them were persons who
were young taking lessons in the
orchestra band at school and then there
were those who were keeping their lips
in shape those who were older and now
had time to practice and we're part of
all this come with me again to a
congregation where sermons now our
interactive and the way they've done the
sermons is they have two screens now up
in front and they have I don't know what
you call her but I think she's a sensor
so people are invited during the sermon
to tweak their responses to text their
responses to texts their responses as
the person is preaching and they don't
just go raw up on the screen you could
imagine
skip and I were talking about what might
happen if this would occur but as that
material cups up on the screen the
preacher has a screen in front of her
and what she does in the course of her
sermon as she preaches that she also
responds to glosses that are emerging as
a sermon is underway and now what's
occurring is is that the sermons are
changing and they're becoming the work
of the people led by an arid I trained
biblical scholar who's done her work and
who opens up the text in ways that are
accessible to the people you wouldn't do
this way you might let me take you to
another congregation a small
congregation up on the edge of the
forest nish wan Minnesota a person from
3m retires and comes as a chemical
engineer who's got an interest in
technology and some what he does is he
discovers that there's a cable
television station that will in fact put
their worship service on television at
two o'clock in the morning so he does a
single camera video enough service
there's a seventh grader whose a geek
who's watching him doing this and says
single camera doesn't do it you've got
to have multiple cameras and they can be
remotely controlled so the 73-year old
retired engineer who is interested
electronics and the seventh grade acne
pimply geek start working together and
now they got cameras and the preacher
said I look way better when they edit me
than when I'm actually preaching I one
day and insomniac shows up at church
someone who can't sleep
in the middle of the night Cap'n's to
own the local local paper company it's
got a lot in his mind he can't sleep in
the night and now this worship service
impacts his experience he sees that the
worship service now gets paid for and
has put on television on Sunday
afternoons late as people are reaping
from the weekend and gathering for going
into the week in this jammed lifestyle
of families their congregation this
little congregation up on the edge of
the forest has doubled in size because a
geek who is in seventh grade and a
retired chemical engineer have been
putting together an extension of their
worshipping community out into the world
that changed a some niak and he threw
the work of the congregation is changing
the community dear friends in Christ to
work intergenerational II is not too
dumb the church down its to break it
open and it's why I think we have Jesus
saying let the little children come
don't send them away don't send them
away but little children come for it to
them belongs the kingdom of heaven so I
come today as someone who's studying
ecclesiology the question what does it
mean to be the church what does it mean
to be the church let's leave that for a
moment and pick up these three spheres
and take a look at a couple of other
dimensions of this and see if we can get
at it in the research that skipped
referred to that I've done with West
black a Southern Baptist from
southwestern baptist theological
seminary and john roberto from just down
the road apiece John Roberto Roman
Catholic done research for the
conference of Bishops for years we
studied 131 congregations and
in those 131 congregations we we
discovered 44 faith assets that
profoundly influenced the development of
the young men and women in their
congregations those between the ages of
13 and 18 and we discovered that in some
of those congregations the primary
influence in the lives of those young
people was the intergenerational
functioning of the whole congregation
we'll take a look at that in a minute we
discovered that in some of those
congregations it was the age level youth
ministry that was working particularly
in developing relationships with those
who had a particular set of life
experiences a particular grammar
particular location in the community
they were doing age level youth
ministries and others we discovered it
was domestic Church it was a history of
moms and dads and grandmas and grandpas
and uncles and aunts single and married
people who had a if you will in their
family a culture of faith practices and
faith conversation that deeply
influenced these young people we also
discovered there were some congregations
that had in fact over time cultivated
all three of these and young people
lived in that sweet spot of not only
hearing the grand God stories but also
experiencing them practiced first of all
in an intergenerational community unlike
anything they experienced anywhere where
do young people these days have
available to them an intergenerational
community that is intentionally engaged
in each other in such a way that
everyone is respected rare and here it
was secondly in these places they
discovered that there were people
overhearing the existential questions of
teenagers in their own language like
what does it mean to
my skin what's it like to look in the
mirror and have my body image what's it
like to take the wings of the morning
and fly to moments of highest ecstasy
and slip into the depths of deepest
despair because of the adrenaline or the
Tata stirrin or whatever is flowing in
my blood on a particular day how do I
live in my own skin how do i how do I be
me how do I be me when my parents have
in fact a roadmap all worked out for me
and that roadmap is certain SATs certain
schools certain standards of living
carried beyond the ones that we've been
able to imagine where's the opportunity
to look deep into the particularity of
the beauty of what God has put into a
young person's life have you ever looked
into the face of a 13 year old and fully
understood what you've seen there whoa
it's just a delight to discover what's
going on but how does one do that or how
does one hang out with them in such a
way that they're figuring out how to
hold up the other end of a stick I mean
by there how do you be a friend I'm
friending you
so what does that entail what's it like
to be a son or a daughter what's it like
to fall in love what's it like to get
beat on and get pissed off and deal with
one's anger how does one be in between
what's it like to love a neighbor you
know these things these same existential
questions that are alive in the lives of
their parents and their grandparents are
as alive in the lives of young people
but the grammar the location is
different and so age level youth
ministries we discovered learn the
grammar step into their lives and walk
with them in ways that have totally
different functions in many cases than
their parents I don't I don't yet
understand how to be in what's happened
in the last 18 months in regard to the
world of texting social media I how to
be a part of it but I don't get when I
sit next to them they text me rather
than talking to me and I get that
enables them to be in contact with
literally thousands of people I'm
frightened in the exposure that I see
regularly taking place of the bullying
but I wonder what's going on in their
existence when the way they touch me is
via screen excuse me I want to be
touched I want to be hugged I wanted to
look into someone's eyes and by a
dinosaur I don't know
but we're invited to join them in that
process third home um what does it mean
to have a mom was it mean to have a dad
I met him at the doorway he was now 45
minutes late from the time he said he'd
be home at the car and it was snowing
minnesota's like that the snow had been
falling vertically and now it was
falling horizontally couldn't see a
thing could have called and he didn't
now he drives in 45 minutes late he
hadn't said anything I mean you have a
cell phone for goodness sakes i met him
in the doorway and I said well have you
been they've been stuck in a snowbank
and they've been digging themselves out
it's not what they needed to hear he
from his dad when we had breakfast the
next morning you could cut the air with
a knife his dad and he and was like that
for three days he's stubborn his I
finally I went downstairs and I suppose
mostly looking at my shoes we had a guy
talk said John I blew it I was so
anxious and frightened and thinking
about my worry I had no sense of where
you were coming from I'm sorry
I screwed up and he looking at his shoes
converse all-stars bright pink long
shorts was January said I sometimes
screw up to dad let me know you screwed
up it's okay it's okay that's Sunday
morning confession absolution
restoration of life on Saturday night in
the bedroom in language that Jon and I
both understood so when I'm wondering
with you about is this I don't know
where you're at where your location is
but from our research we have learned
there are many if you will entrées into
this world a profound influence one of
them can be a preacher responding to a
contra men saying you hand out all those
empty pop cans and or another might be a
mom a dad who sits with you and says I
don't get it how do you parent a
teenager for God's sakes I knew how to
be with her when she was a little girl
but I am her dad and she is breast for
goodness sakes why do I do now how do I
be with her what do we say or the
opportunity to create an alternative
lifestyle a counterculture around the
service trip mission trip and worship
and hanging out together
place that's safe place where one
doesn't have to live up to mom and dad's
expectations or the worlds but a place
where one can discover ones unfolding
giftedness let me just take you down a
quick list of some ways to think about
that and and then I want to pick up on
your questions as you've seen some of
this take that handout you have and get
beyond the the front sheet and start
taking a look at those categories just
run your eye down those categories of
the 44 assets that we picked up in our
research you'll have some more
opportunity to look at these I don't
want you to spend so much time with them
that you get overwhelmed I don't know
about you but when we finish the
research and I took a look at the 44 I
thought oh my god there's no way there's
no way first of all those 44 are
individually pieces that we discovered
gold if you will nuggets that we
discovered arising out of our study of
the hundred and thirty-one congregations
so it's a bringing together of if you
will the wisdom of the Willing those who
are participating in this process let me
take a cut out now not as someone doing
ecclesiology getting after the life of
the church but now let me take a cut at
it as a theologian when I finished
looking at this work I discovered what I
would call a watershed in these
congregations whether it was in the
congregation itself with the youth age
level ministry or in their families
there was a grammar and the grammar was
deeply theological let me give you
examples
God has been at work in her life
yesterday when I prayed I had the sense
that God was present when bill showed up
at my wrestling match it was like God
was accompanying me and a scary fearful
moment in my life when I talked to God
these days it's like a kite I can't see
god it's like a kite above the clouds I
can't see god it's like a kite string
with the kite above the clouds it's like
I can't see God but somehow i get God is
listening and God understands what I'm
saying do you notice who's the subject
of the sentence of these sentences it's
God here's here's how I learned their
theology the subject of the sentences
was some language representing the great
Trinity God Jesus spirit the verbs were
active they were present tense they
didn't talk about my or our or I or once
upon a time they talked about God as
though God was living present active and
that threw them among them in them God
was up to dealing with life itself and
particularly God's mission in the world
the present active tense of God what I
discovered in the research is that I
think young people have crap detectors
and I I think even though they don't
have the language to work it they're
incredibly thoughtful careful
theologians if there is this sense of
something afoot our God is alive a God
whose present a god who's engaged in
transforming the world and even through
them thus the power of mission trips
that's the power of lively worship that
grows out of their language for them
there becomes then a draw there's
something going on here I think when I
was here before I told you about a 17
year old i discovered met in one of
these congregations she said my family I
like them it's a good place I'm cared
for and loved their school my school is
a great place when I'm here when I'm
with this people when I hang out here
they mess with my life I said what do
you mean by that she said they see
things in me that I don't see they lift
up questions that are gnawing at me that
I don't have the language to to explore
but they put language to it and then
somehow I experience here that life is
bigger than us and more than about me
that someone someplace and then she used
this language the one whose heart beats
at the center of the universe is it
worker she had met the God that I study
in the old and new Testament and the
great tradition of the church and she
was experiencing the thing itself here
it was
so if we take a look at what we
discovered in these congregations you
will see a particular theology emerging
in these first six assets God's living
presence possess a sense of God's living
presence in community at worship through
study and in service those are ancient
tradition words community word and
sacrament drawn together by the power of
the Spirit mutual conversation and
consolation of God's people worship
practice ritual study the ancient
process of the synagogue's working the
texts and in-service following in the
footsteps of the life of the one who who
was the man for others centrality of
faith recognize and participate in God's
sustaining and transforming life and
work the operative words here are
sustaining and transforming something
happens here emphasizes prayer practice
the presence of God is individuals
communities through prayer and worship
if God is alive and God is present and
God is up to something I've got to talk
to God and I've got to listen to God and
so we listen together we speak together
we help each other develop a language if
you will for conversing with God focus
on discipleship committed to know and
following Jesus there was a progression
that I regularly saw in these
congregations and in the age level
ministries from what I would call it's
okay to be an outlier could show up but
along the way in this community of
hospitality you're invited deeper into
the pin into the life of the community
ala discovering spiritual gifts ala
commitment to being there with and for
the other Allah following the deep
questions of the faith
like in the Psalms in the wisdom
literature in job to the point of
turning the corner of discovering that
God is at work through the leadership as
of these young people as they follow
Christ in the world a with me
discipleship discipleship ah the
importance of Scripture living in an
ongoing dialogue lectio divina dwelling
in the word centrality of mission
consistently witnessed serve and promote
moral responsibility in seeking justice
ah I'm here to say that the heart of
youth ministry is not techne the
critical issue youth ministry is not
learning some new way to text although
one might want to be working in that
world a heart of youth ministry is
theology so our notion our understanding
our way of living in the presence of a
God who is present and transformative
let me go one last place in this in
terms of getting at parents in between
you can take a look at these assets
let's go to family involvement before we
pick up question and answer with one
another how might how my family's be
helpful many people say it's really
difficult for us to find any way to work
with a particular family in terms of
their lifestyle every moment is
scheduled being a church is okay as long
as it doesn't interfere with
you can fill in the blank so how does
one enter into the lives of parents and
help them understand and enrich the
lives of those in the family here are
five elements that we discovered that
could be accessed not only one on one
but also through programmatic processes
now use one as we close the development
of the faith of a parent is critical to
the faith of their child Chris Smith and
I and others who have worked on this in
soul searching makes the argument that
in fact young people regularly don't
move in their faith maturity beyond the
faith maturity of their parents so can
it be that strong preaching can it be
that dolt Christian education is
critical to youth ministry seem so
promotes family practices parents engage
youth and family and conversations
prayer Bible reading and service that
nurture faith and life I don't know how
it worked or how it might work in
families these days but families once in
a while eat together
once in a while my one wonder in a
sermon about what it's like to be a
Gandhi with the deep sense of gratitude
for sustenance we talk about nutrition
talk about dieting might there be a
place in that conversation for where is
God at work in creation and how do we
join God in creation in terms of what we
do to feed ourselves to feed the world
what might those rituals look like these
days come Lord Jesus be our guest and
let these gifts to us be blessed the old
way it happened at our house until my
mother started asking questions and then
around the dinner table we were blessed
with a yeshiva Table Talk sorry I'm a
Lutheran
reflects family harmony expressions of
respect and love create an atmosphere
promoting faith I get this the night in
john's room with us looking at our shoes
asking each other for forgiveness how
does one translate the gifts of the
Spirit like forgiveness into the
lifestyle of husbands and wives how
parents and kids a brothers and sisters
what does it look like that's what karen
was saying to me when she said on Sunday
morning you hand out all those empty pop
cans on Wednesday I hand a few back to
you had nothing much of significance
ever passes between us I had all the
words right I knew about contrition
confession absolution restoration of
life an amendment of life all the way
back through the history of the church
transformed in my own Reformation
tradition I had it down I had written
essays I'd passed the tests I had not
translated it into language that Karen
and her grandmother could use eclipse
parents offers instructions and guidance
that nurture parental faith and equips
parents for nurturing faith at home
foster parent youth relationships offers
parent youth activities that strengthen
parent youth relationships let me close
with this and then pick up your
questions I'm on a plane out of
Melbourne Australia 14 and a half hour
flight into San Francisco we get into
the air an hour hour and a half and they
feed us to put us asleep
we get our meal and I'm a little guy
sitting in a row of four in the center
of a 747-400 and I turned to the person
next to me he's long gangly guy and
after making some small congregation a
small conversation I say to him so do
you go to church I thought I had a
captive audience he's buckled in you
look back at me and said funny that you
should ask I just quit he said well who
are you anyway I didn't tell him right
away I simply said so you quit how come
said well my wife and I and our two
children who are nine eleven are
presbyterian but from Long Beach we're
baptized as Presbyterians we had our
children baptized as Presbyterians and
we have in fact been faithful in church
until about six weeks ago so I said tell
me how come you quit said well we came
home from church one Sunday we looked at
each other kids Barbara and I and said
so what happened today anything what
occurred we asked the kids they colored
we looked at one another and said
Barbara and I said did we make a
difference in anyone's life this morning
did anyone make a difference in our life
this morning why are we doing this he is
a major business consultant he had just
been in Australia brokering a deal
between it a Australian iron mining
company and a huge foundry in China he
said regularly as I do my work they'll
look down the table at me and asked me
to speak into value
leyden questions he was telling me I
practice ethics and he said I regularly
don't know what say I've got my business
sense down I've got my negotiation
skills down but I don't have a
foundation from which to respond and I'm
not getting any help so we quit so I
said to him did you tell your pastor and
he said so who are you I felt like
saying I'm god I'm the Holy Spirit but I
still didn't tell him I said go see you
administer so he said now you have to
tell me who you are so I told him I was
an academic dean at a seminary I was a
god guy gave him my card we had small
talk I thought it's done about a month
later I received a call this is craig
from long beach i went to see my
Minister I said so he said he listened
to me thank God for this non defensive
Presbyterian pastor he said not that's
not all he invited me to be in next week
sermon whoa said what did he do he said
he interviewed me and he asked me to
talk about my life and my questions as a
consultant and he and I started dialogue
about from what values does one give
answers to questions
after the service 13 people came to talk
to Craig and his pastor and said we're
that close we're that close as you were
to leaving to be coming if you will the
fastest-growing religious group in
America you know them bernards down
affiliated the knots this morning this
morning you scratched where we itch you
put cool water on the parched places in
our lives today in Long Beach California
there is a book study group on ethics
that is grounded in a business
consultants hunger his kids are back a
church and they are in fact being
profoundly influenced by the lives of
their mother and father dear friends in
Christ your communities are poised to be
deeply value added not just to spiritual
seekers but to anyone who is spiritually
opened it's the power of youth ministry
let me stop have you been a long as cold
in here huh you put your coat on for
goodness sakes let me see we've got some
minutes of skip told me we need to make
certain that we had time to do this and
we do I'm wondering are there questions
right off they want to ask if there
isn't I want to put a couple to you but
let's check in and see if you've been
able to follow me questions of
clarification or challenges you might
want to make yes sir
sounds like a generational ministry
would necessitate a lot of people doing
more than they currently do yes my
community they like me to do to you yes
so how do i how do I make myself less
important there it's a great four years
question to do this calls for people to
be involved and in in my community
people expect me I'm the hired gun huh
I'm to do it I'm the one who's got the
time how do we do this in such a way
that other than I doing this all or me
doing this others can be doing this
let's go back to nisswa Minnesota the 73
year old who is doing the recording of
the service and and then the geek kid
who found him and so forth I think first
of all its assets hunting it's looking
around and and many times i think it's
it's in the most unusual places in this
case a 73 year old with a camera and and
then on the basis of what one sees there
and imagines encouraging those gifts and
encouraging those relationships and for
those people who are doing that work to
in fact have a place in the scheme of
things so i think one of the ways to get
at that is is to is to be a talent scout
it's to be an asset hunter and and then
to work with those assets a second i
think is to take the present rituals of
our faith life and breathe out of the
tradition new life into those rituals I
no longer preach like I once preached I
hardly ever preach a monologue anymore
because we're alive today in a
thoroughly interactive society and so
I'm keen now to discover differing ways
whereby what we can do is we can
unleashed
capacity of the congregation to witness
to each other so that Proclamation and
and and marteria witness end up both
being a part of the presentation of the
gospel to the community as I've been
doing so I be discovered two things
first of all it's difficult to get
started you know for for someone to see
that their experience of God and their
struggle with God and their struggle
with God with life questions is in fact
a critical element of the life of the
community so the first way I've started
to do that is they have a couple of
stools and I'll walk out of the the the
pulpit invites someone to come and take
about three to five minutes just to
interview them around a question that's
essential to the sermon and what has
happened on the basis of that is others
come up to me afterwards and say you
know you know you know I had this happen
you know and now I've got a whole cast
of characters that I might use in terms
of preaching so I so on the one hand I
think it's tough difficult to get
started but once one has gotten it
rolling people began to imagine
themselves in the process third thing
I'll say is in the Trinity I'll speak
for myself as a Lutheran now we're
really high on jesus Lutheran's are okay
especially on the work of Christ we're
kind of skittish about the spirit
although in the third article we get
some good stuff going however sir so for
me the New Testament notion of the gifts
of the Spirit and to start working
together in a congregation to ask so
what's your gift what's my gift how
might our gifts be used to support the
community and to become talent scouts
together to pray to test the tryout and
to do that down some
particular roads so for example kids I
find are particularly helpful in terms
of writing prayers there regularly more
honest direct and speak out of their own
worlds than I do so I'm just beginning
to play with some of those ideas and I
would encourage you to take up that
question with those around you and and
and and it'll take up I would guess a
kind of life of its own in your place
but it will be I think pardon English
dang difficult to get started
so yes don't happen the email said the
title of her talk was gonna have
something to do with his double-time
paper yeah and can you explain what
ain't wrong yeah yeah what I've been
what I've been doing today is to
articulate what youth ministry looks
like opposite different 180 degrees the
other direction than a Pied Piper let me
come at the Pied Piper notion in the 51
years that I've been doing this I've
seen youth ministry dominated by an
ocean and we'll hire someone for 20
hours expect them to work 50 and pay
them for 10 and and as we do so as we do
so we'll expect them to have a 12-string
guitar huge tennis shoes a volleyball
and and and a spirit that is always at a
hundred and if you will 50 miles an hour
and that this person becomes the center
of relationship with kids on programs
activities becomes the symbol bear of
youth ministry in the congregation and
the ministry rises and falls on this
person so then this person if she is
really good at what she does if he is
really good at what he does creates a
following a following creates a
following and the senior minister is
really really proud because she or he
can brag know about our church has got
kids then this person then this person
goes down or then this person leaves or
some perceptive person says
you know in our congregation our kids
don't worship Jesus they worship you and
their notion of faith is narrow as it's
seen in us or if we leave then the
program leaves if we leave then the
thing leave I did that twice nearly
killed myself and got challenged by
better theologians than I to rethink
youth ministry ecclesiological II that's
a that's a terribly distorted view of
the church in terms of how it works so
that's what I'm pushing back against
what I think it requires is a couple of
if you will stages I actually think one
if one's going to be an effective youth
leader one needs to have some of the
qualifications of a Pied Piper love kids
can be can hang with kids ah picks up on
a capacity to do faith talk with kids
can accompany them on journeys where you
become a trusted person we're a lot of
that's what Pied Pipers in fact did but
then comes that process of how to
multiply these gifts among others and I
think that's being a talent scout
looking around finding others
particularly among the kids themselves
developing leadership and so there comes
to be a second stage where now one is
joined by a team then there's a third
stage and here's where the senior
ministers really important and you
discover that the book that John Roberto
and West black and I wrote together the
spirit and cultured youth ministry
speaks about the senior minister
becoming a supporter and a strong voice
and taking on the congregation's view
that youth ministry will be a thing done
over here rather than youth ministry
done in the heart of what's taking place
including high value on age level youth
ministry sorry I didn't go there I just
jumped in to the alternative yeah so let
me excuse me let me ask you if you were
to put your finger on the most hopeful
sign the most hopeful experience that
you are having in your ministry where is
that what is it what are you seeing
emerging as being a strong engaging
intersection of the gospel of the life
of the triune God with the life of kids
these days just quickly let's just pick
up what that might be if you were to say
so it comes to your head raise your hand
and say it okay yes
tree with more than just marking time in
the congregation of really feeling
engaging and watching the young kids
looking to them as more than just cool
kids really receive how many of you in
this room we're at some point in time a
part of a congregation or a part of a
youth ministry that in fact influenced
you any of you look around yeah powerful
what else one thing yes are you actually
believe it we are that we are genuinely
interested in their perspective and not
I'm just regurgitating what they think
we want them to say and so to actually
starting to speak up and offering their
views and seeing that we're using that
to build on our conversations with them
you know so that hearing that their
voice is being heard yeah hearing them
into voice listening taking them
seriously yes the most hopeful thing I
think it's attracting are you uh-huh we
can perceive to serve and to make a
difference and the fact that that hunger
is there that's a very price lug a step
that we are there if we detect that
hunger we can help feed the hungry and
connect them with something that's
meaningful in terms of what church
really is do you hear what she say the
service learning mission trip phenomenon
that reflects young people's deep
commitment or at least sense of I'm
wanting to be involved in making a
difference is that is that common I see
some heads nodded there
others yes put my came together to to do
things together because really there's
not enough people in each church so the
the seminarian that we have likes
working the family ministry has been
working with this particular group and
the hopeful signs what we see is that
the kids are saying what they want out
of church they want they want to come
together and feel the community it's
different than what their parents expect
where they want to go and do things in
the world that make a difference yeah
they want that and and to give them the
ear to say what they want has allowed
them to claim it in a different way so
what's happening is that they're
speaking out about church as it might
morph transform into the future and
that's somewhat different than it is now
so yes they are wanting one that's the
hopeful sign I see it's like at the
beginning they showed up because a few
parents said well you're going to go to
this thing and they SAT around staring
at each other for a while but now
they're starting to to express what they
want to learn how to pray and things
that they don't feel like they've been
able to pick up in the past in some
senses it's getting I hear closer to the
essence of the practicing of faith
itself
and our church embracing that because we
have no separate sunday school I mean
we're all together on sunday yeah there
you've got an intergenerational group
right there yeah yeah so let's go yes
please speak loudly if they can bring
someone from outside love it's great
there was nae have their own networks
fair evangelist so let's switch just for
a moment what's the most nettlesome
dastardly difficult element resistance
that gets in the way of you doing what
you're trying to do what's getting in
the way if you were to put your finger
on on on one or two of those let's hear
say more just let me give you the Mike
when you were describing and I wrote
this down most congregations expect to
hire someone for 20 hours a week I'm
hired 20 hours a week yeah they expect
me to work 50 hours a week and they pay
me for ten and it's that's exactly what
it is how do you even start to explain
to a congregation how youth ministry is
done like I'm just at a loss as to how
to explain it's going to take more than
three months for this to happen yeah
yeah let me give a couple responses to
that I would encourage you do you have a
pastor at your church okay HISHE do you
have a young person who is demonstrated
interest in what you're doing okay do
you have an adult who has I would
encourage you the four of you to start a
conversation
around what you've just said this isn't
working this set of expectations just
isn't going to do it how might we go to
work together on rethinking this so it
might work so you the four of you take
up this experience and then you what you
might do is either go to the website the
the exemplar youth ministry website or
get a hold of the spirit and culture of
youth ministry you just thumb through it
and there's some sections there that I
think are pregnant with ideas
possibilities that might be grist for
the mill in terms of thinking your way
forward in terms of what you might do
right yeah you're welcome what else you
hit a chord it looks like what else is
in the way
you are speak to that yeah here I was
just going to say a step in a general
direction we did are you Sunday recently
and eighty percent of the kids were
knocked out for a variety of reasons so
I would say maybe not sports but
priorities that the bottom thing on the
list and I think you mentioned in your
speaking was that's great if we have
time for it or something along those
lines whether it's sports or midterms or
academics or whatever everything is
above the church call and where that's
not the case those are the kids that
really stand out so I mean we were
talking about hopes those few kids that
say no it's important that I'm here as a
hope but that's only ten twenty percent
there let's wonder for a moment about a
very different society I don't quite
know what this post post modern
lifestyle might best be called but as in
terms of faith communities I see most
people are outliers now in terms of any
sense of commitment to religious
practice and for those outliers to get
into whatever communities of practice
there are there has to be something that
draws them into that process and it in
the beginning they're not coming because
they're committed it's some value added
it's someone inviting them to come the
first set of I think critical element
elements are sets of what I would call
hospitality it's okay to come in and out
as an outlier and then there there is
within the spheres of what admit what
unfolds I think a series of people
taking steps depending on who they are
in terms of what the Holy Spirit and
what we're doing with them engages them
in doing with us
and then at some point in time there are
crossover places where people begin to
say no more hockey on sunday morning I'm
going to do this now that's way way way
way from here to that place of
discipleship my guess is we're all going
to be practicing faith in such a world
and how to think about that staging how
to think about those processes how to
even put together strategies that enable
us to do some of that I think are
critical one of them when I consult with
congregations that we use is how to make
Sunday morning worship into a community
experience of worship community building
and some moment of learning so that
whatever that is if people step into
that sphere if you will that that
counterculture the the hospitality is
palpable and one begins to use that as a
framework from which to in fact move the
other is one on one I still believe that
that one on one relationship has the
potential for beginning to deepen and
spread in terms of those possibilities
yes here comes
my guess you history you've proved
attendees or kids who drive because I
think you touched on something about you
know kids aren't going to rise above the
level that their parents experienced in
church and while on one side I have more
and more parents coming to me saying oh
my kid was talking about X and
Confirmation and I didn't learn that and
you know really wanting to have those
one-on-one come come come conversations
I think on the other end of the spectrum
are the parents who literally drop their
kids off for required confirmation
classes or worship and having better
themselves in five years and really
annoyed with you that there's any kind
of expectation and you know there's
there's a gray area in between but
parental sort of buying is really
difficult I think yes had the mic back
yeah i just wanted to sort of respond to
that i mean i think that one like sign
of hope for me has been kids it's scary
but true that kids have a lot of power
these days in their families I when I
was growing up going to church wasn't an
option it just went but that's not the
case anymore and I find that that's
scary but what's hopeful about it is if
you build a program that the kids want
to be at they will come if you if you
build relationships with them in
connections with them two weeks ago I
had a mom called me and she was a little
miffed because they had to cancel their
ski trip because their kid wanted to
come to the confirmation event that I
was like I'm so sorry for you so on the
one hand that's terrifying to me how
much kids have power and it's terrifying
to them too I think but it's true and if
the kid says I want to be there a lot of
times the parent will follow suit so I
don't know that's been a point of hope
for me as well as terror yeah mixed bag
let's play with that little what I see
in what you're saying is tending that
journey from being an outlier to
stepping into commitment within whatever
that faith experience is that is youth
ministry to the point where this person
says this matters to me this matters to
me more than a or b or c and what would
I here in what you're saying is don't
underestimate the power that young
people can have if they commit to
something yes sir
yes indeed I think for us one of the
things is parents in general many
different ways is probably the biggest
obstacle at times within the youth
ministry yeah so and with with that even
with the answers they were giving it I
think kind of encompasses that but my
question is do you see as you study and
as you've been to all these different
churches doing research do you see youth
ministry doing more family ministry
where they're reaching out to parents
ministering to parents and kind of you
know partnering with the parents in what
they're doing because for our
experiences a lot of times we have
amazing ministry with the young people
but then they go back home and whether
it's a mission trip or a camp we do with
them but the biggest problem is the hell
back home here do you do you hear what
he's saying that's a great question the
answer is yes in terms of a great many
differing ways that we see we've seen in
these congregations people working with
parents and almost always it's in the
context of the struggle that you named
it's it's never like all solved it's
it's like being worked at in one of the
congregation's there's a team of three
parents who take it on themselves to
interpret whatever is going on at church
and whatever is going on within youth
ministry and whatever is being learned
about the value of your parents
encouraging their kids in faith and
interpreting that to parents they their
role their role is is that they
understand themselves to be ambassadors
for the life of faith with young people
with the young people's parents and in a
couple of congregations
they do that what i would call covertly
you know they they know you know who's
in the bridge club and who's gone to the
spa or whatever and and they utilize
those networks as a way of carrying out
those messages a second I've seen is the
use of sunday morning particularly
worship to do this one congregation we
saw head a a single person married
person family grandparent parenting
moment toward the end of the worship
service and this happened to be a
Lutheran congregation so they used the
notion vocation and it was it was kind
of like a life moment where we're at the
end of this at the end of the service
says the sending took place around the
notion of all right let's rehearse now
what it is we have been doing in worship
for this next week and so they they they
do a brief if you will practice or
exercise or idea exploration with
persons in terms of how families can
better be in each other's lives
particularly out of the life of faith
and every Sunday there's three minutes
or five minutes and so they use Sunday
morning as a way of doing family
ministry when they've already got a
captive audience a final way to that I
saw happening is the congregation
surveyed families and asked if you were
to list the top 10 concerns in your
family if you to list what you struggle
with what what provides difficulty for
you in your life they took that survey
played that information back to families
in the congregation to to prioritize
and then over a year that a series of
sermons so they weren't always preaching
on the prick up etext for the day but
laced in doing a series of sermons what
happened is when they tracked their
worship attendance there were these
spikes so those are at least a bit of
what we saw there was a there was a
church in Nebraska Roman Catholic Church
whether it was this this this lay man
who just wouldn't let go of this thing
and worked with the schools and the
parents and so forth and the parish
became the what i would call centre
family center for the whole community
out of what he did what he did one guy
who got this sort of under his if you
will skin great question we in the book
we also lay out some of that try to get
some handles on all of that yes
yes I'll just say a little and and then
they're all listed in the book or and
the website you can go to the website
you can find the whole list of them
they're all across the country they were
in 70 nominations Roman Catholic
Methodist Presbyterian mission covenant
lutheran Assemblies of God missing one
but there you have them kind of the
spectrum of American Christianity six
regions of the country rural urban
suburban small medium large and they're
they're listed so you could just take a
look in the book we we put every one of
them in there okay it's time to wrap up
looks like just to say thank you for
gathering for someone who's been at this
for 51 years and who sees that the
impact of what you're doing to come to
room of persons like yourself is an
honor for me our great this is sacred
ground thank you for what you do god's
blessings on what you do let's pray as
you leave grace is God we thank you for
life for the capacities to think
question decide suffer celebrate we
thank you for our lives to live this
Tuesday februari afternoon new haven
connecticut Lord Jesus Christ we thank
you that in baptism you can only draw
son to yourself but you give us to each
other and to the world I thank you for
giving these men and women to the young
generation of this region and to those
young men and women to their church
we ask now that you would be with us as
we take leaves send your Holy Spirit
stir in our spirits give us hope and
courage and wisdom thank you for
including us in your work in your name
we play Lord Jesus Christ mmm